what about those rows do you ever do
those because I did I did the uh the I
did the Chevy Chase roast and it was one
of the worst nights of my life why
because you know with when you're an
angry guy you know you know generally
when Chevy's angry too yeah but he he
didn't want to be there right I mean it
was and you know and I like that guy
when I was I was a kid sure but like I'm
not great with with roasting or I didn't
used to be because when you're angry if
you're insulting somebody it's to hurt
them right so my tone isn't quite right
but I'd written jokes and I'd never done
a rose before but I remember I got up
there and that place was it was the Deus
was big right it was it was huge it was
not you know I'm not I'd never done it
before right and you know thank God they
sweetened that thing because literally I
I got up on stage it must have been 2
000 people in that it was right over
here at the Hilton it was in and I was
just bombing you know and you know like
and Chevy's sitting right there he
doesn't give a [__] everybody I know in
comedy and I'm bombing and at some point
I'm like oh my God this is going
horribly right and then I Gotta Laugh
and it kind of broke the jokes were good
but like I literally like I could feel
my personality disintegrating and I was
starting to sweat and I after that night
I went up into my hotel room I was with
my buddy Sam website you know he's a
he's a he writes novels and I'm I'm
literally on the verge of tears I'm like
I can't do this anymore
you mean comedy in general everything
yeah what the hell was going on because
here you are waiting for a big break
you're trying to get your your your
profile up you get in front of a big
crowd you know it's going to be on
Comedy Central and you [__] tank I'm
tanking yeah and you're like how can
that be well it happens yeah you know I
mean it's part of what you say it was
your anger because you were so angry I
just didn't come off fun well no I
actually I wasn't angry I just wanted
the jokes to work I wasn't angry at him
like I just like doing those jokes it's
hard for me to deliberate how to do them
I've gotten better that was a few years
ago it's a different style right it is
it's not like your stand-up bag no no it
is it's definitely there has to be a
warm-heartedness to it or it's gonna
it's not but I just wasn't it just
wasn't working but they sweetened it and
people can't understand when I when I
talk about this oh yeah it look good to
me and I'm like dude they they have who
was dead right and it was 2 000 dead
room it was not and that's and there's
no more feeling alone that is the
Loneliest feeling in the world it's
amazing you ever even went into stand-up
comedy with all your your self-doubt and
and all this pain yeah I don't know it
was uh I don't know that I ever got into
it initially to be an entertainer right
like I think I got into it because it's
like when I watched comedy when I was a
kid it was like those guys got an angle
on things they can understand you know
they've got a way of managing the world
right
oh